ours is the fury
these are the words of the black stag of
baratheon
a battle cry echoed throughout the land
in rebellion when i
robert baratheon the first of his name
seized the iron throne from the mad king
aerys targaryen
ending a dynasty nearly 300 years old
house baratheon was born in the wars of
conquest when aegon the dragon invaded
westeros
aegon sent his commander orris baratheon
to take storm's end
argilac the arrogant the last of the
storm kings foolishly left the safety of
his stronghold
and met the baratheon warlord in open
battle
argilac was soundly defeated
and oris took his lands his holdings
and his daughter
horace was said to be a half-brother to
aegon targaryen
if this were true a little blood of the
dragon mingled with that of the stag in
those days
the seat of house baratheon is storm's
end
a legendary keep raised in the age of
heroes
it overlooks shipbreakers bay where
legend has it that durham the first
storm king raised the keep with the aid
of bran the builder of house stark
forging a centuries-long connection with
the stormlands and the north
after aegon's conquest of the seven
kingdoms the baratheons remained loyal
enough to the crown while targaryen
kings came and went
but loyalty has its limits
when rhaegar targaryen heiresses vile
son and air abducted lyanna stark i
betrothed
my beloved
it was time to act
we raised our banners baratheon stark
john aaron and the tullys
united in rebellion against rhaegar and
his father the mad king
[Music]
we were victorious and took the iron
throne
that bit of dragon blood in my veins
came in well as it made me a distant
relation to the targaryen dynasty blood
of my long-lost ancestor oris
the truth of it is
i took it
tarth has lulled many a novice sailor
into complacency
our lush island sits on calm blue water
like an emerald set into a sapphire you
would never guess that such a vision is
only the sheath hiding the blade of
shipbreaker bay with its treacherous
tides unpredictable gales and sharp
rocks lurking just below the water's
surface
the storms that blow through the bay
water the kingswood and rainwood two of
the great forests of westeros
and they give the stormlands their name
even without our weather we have more
than earned our name in strife
the first storm king darren
started his reign by declaring war on
the gods themselves
he loved the daughter of the sea god and
the wind goddess but they forbade the
union
at their wedding the gods unleashed
their might pulling down his hold and
killing all of durham's family and
guests though his wife shielded him
darren vowed to rebuild and when he did
the gods again destroyed his home
his councillors begged him to retreat
inland but he would not abandon his war
finally
with the council of the children of the
forest or perhaps a young brand the
builder
darren raised a seventh castle that
tries they might and still do
the wind and sea gods could not tear
asunder
darren took the name god's grief and
called his new home storm's end
having beaten the waters to the east
the storm kings turned their gaze to
more practical enemies
the reach riverlands and dawn
for thousands of years the storm kings
fought the gardener kings of the reach
and various families of dawn for control
of the dornish marches just below the
red mountains
the fighting didn't stop until dawn
married into the seven kingdoms a mere
hundred years ago
but still the houses of the stormlands
such as the dondarrions guard the
boneway the mountain pass into the
marches against any dornish incursion
the storm kings had greater luck to
their north
at first
they took the trident from the river
kings and built an empire that stretched
as far as the neck
but then the ironborn swarmed out of
their islands and pushed the storm kings
out of the riverlands
no doubt the ironborn intended to expand
their empire into the stormlands
before they had a chance
aegon targaryen landed with his dragons
while aegon burned the kings of the iron
islands the rock and the reach
his fiercest commander and rumored
bastard brother or his baratheon set out
to subdue the stormlands
no matter how fierce a warrior he was
no one could have embedded his task
storm's end in thousands of years of war
and never fallen
but argilac the storm king chose not to
barricade himself behind its walls and
gave always the battle he must have
hoped for
oris slewed argalac and took argilac's
castle
kingdom daughter sigil and house words
house baratheon became the lord of the
stormlands
targaryen rule quieted the stormlands
for the most part
until robert rebelled against the mad
king
his first challenge came not from the
crown but from his own bannerman who
tried to join forces against him
robert struck first
defeating three armies in a single day
at summerhall
the victory cemented robert's control of
the stormlands and he was able to march
on the reach and riverlands with no
enemy to his rear
yet not all of robert's bannermen sided
with him
so barristan the bold came from the
stormlands
but as the pre-eminent member of aries
kingsguard and greatest night in the
realm sir barristan remained loyal
after robert's decisive victory on the
trident
robert sent his own maester to care for
his countrymen sir
who had suffered grievous wounds whilst
fighting so hard to kill him
later
when the king's slayer betrayed heiress
robert pardoned sir barristan
and even took him onto his own king's
guard
when robert lifted mace tyrell's
ill-managed siege of storm's end and
returned to his ancestral home
he realized the dream of all the
stormlords before him
to rule the seven kingdoms
rebellion
the crimes of house targaryen were too
heinous to go unanswered
the noble houses of baratheon stark and
aaron united to oppose and overthrow the
line of the cursed dragon kings
while ned stark and aaron secured an
alliance with the tullys of riverrun
i called the banners of storm's end and
rode out in force against the mad king
and his minions
gods those were some battles
our first victory occurred at summer
hall where i faced off against an army
of dragon loyalists and won three
battles in a single day three in one day
seven hells that was a glorious day
we tried to take ashford castle in the
reach but the tyrells beat us back
we had to
regroup my army was pursued north by
eris's army and took refuge in the stony
sept in the riverlands
when the targaryen army entered the town
the sept bells told a signal to the
townspeople of the battle that was to
come
as the targaryens searched from house to
house for me the combined forces of ned
stark and the tullys swept into the city
gods what a day that was
it's now known as the battle of the
bells
we overwhelmed the mad king's forces and
sent them scampering back to king's
landing
aerys son rhaegar who started the whole
damn thing finally emerged from hiding
in the south and assembled his own army
to face us
as for the mad king
he must have been pissing himself
the battle that would decide the fate of
the seven kingdoms occurred at the
crossing of the green fork of the
trident river
rhaegar commanded the royal host which
was some forty thousand strong
my forces were outnumbered by nearly
five thousand men
but that didn't matter
they were fresh
but we were battle-hardened and had
justice on our side
as the battle raged around us i faced
off with rhaegar the stag and the dragon
right there in the fort of the river
i fought with the fury of ten men
raining blow after blow up on that vile
prince before burying my warhammer in
his chest
i hit him so hard the rubies on his
armor broke free flinging them into the
stream
they call it the ruby ford now
with that scum rhaegar dead and the
royal army shattered
our next move was to make for king's
landing
but i'd sustained a few wounds in the
battle and was unable to ride
i sent ned stark to the capital to face
the mad king and make him pay for his
crimes